so I'm compassionate than the site
manager of the spacebook data center
i've been here since we broke ground
till now we're breaking into war ground
so the city of Grendel were about 9,000
people Kirk County is about 22,000 it's
a very very rural community you know
while agriculture will always be very
strong for us these data centers will
help us spread out that employment base
we've had every major data center player
on the planet come through this building
share or we're a very very open company
we want to share with other people we
think that when you when you have
something that works it's good but when
you can share with other people and get
input and they can try something and you
continue to share we can only get better
as an industry that's a group and that's
what we're doing here with it yes Jason
our private on your lap to you d be s
user database that is where your profile
is on a disk financial transactions that
are occurring through Facebook and
current cages like this we treat this
just like a bank not every technician
has access to this not every person has
access to the servers the parts that we
replace and change don't come out of
here we deal with is very very securely
because Facebook's put us on the map
other data centers we hope will come
Facebook's been able to operate that
facility incredibly efficiently because
of our climate I think other people who
come to town and take advantage of that
climate we measure temperature between
sixty and eighty degrees we want within
our zones and we want to keep about
thirty percent relative humidity within
a data center so this just shows us
where we're at
we've had some people's like can we call
this data center of course you can would
you like to do pence okay because that's
how openly transparently want to be as a
company and that's what the bar i'm
pretty happy but they said it's going to
bring thousands of jobs for local
businesses i I know that here in the gym
they get talked about a lot in the
things they do around town and I see
their name and everything everything
from one end of primal to the other so
yeah I'd say they've been a blessing for
our community in every aspect